- Are you just trying to get people
to do things that are impossible,
so they look ridiculous?
(upbeat music)
- I don't even know what
muscle to flex to wiggle my...
- Are they moving?
- I know how to wiggle my ears,
it's been a talent that I've been
pretty proud of, since I was a young tot.
You ready?
- You're moving your scalp,
what the hell? (laughs)
- This is a good party trick.
- Do you know why some
people can wiggle their ears?
It's an evolutionary thing.
'Cause you know how
animals can move their ears
so specifically to hear noises?
It's one of those muscles
that we don't really need,
but we still have.
- I can try to lick my elbow.
I'm not sure I can pull it off.
There's no way.
- (laughs) I'm so far away.
No, can a human do that?
- I can do it!
- (laughs) I can fit a
knuckle and a half, that's it.
- I definitely can't put
my whole fist in my mouth,
because I have huge, huge hands.
- No. I'm afraid of
breaking my jaw even trying.
Please show me the footage
of someone who can do that,
because that would be amazing.
- [Voiceover] Wow, you're the first person
that can do that today.
How do you feel about that?
- I've always thought
that I had a big mouth,
but now it's confirmed.
(upbeat music)